why
carrie wow this movie was um
something carrie failed on so many
[ __ ] levels
85 to 90 of the scenes contained
something that just did not
work it felt like a made-for-tv movie
with a
slightly higher budget the directing of
this film absolutely
horrible it's just really [ __ ] bad
this film feels like mean girls with the
tone and
vibe of the first twilight movie the
director just had no idea what kind of
movie she wanted to make it's like she
was saying let's make this a
a teen drama or no no let's make this
horror film she can never find
a way to combine both worlds because i
know carrie's supposed to be like a
variation of that but there are many
variables when you think about horror
film and teen drama and unlike every
scene the director was like [ __ ] it
we're going for a different tone now
most of the actors are just so bad i
felt like
none of them were on the same page for
the kind of film they were trying to
make
some people were really over the top
some people tried being like too real
and then some people were just like man
you're a bad [ __ ] actor the writing
the writing
is so awful there's laughable dialogue
dialogue
that is supposed to be serious but you
find yourself going
shitty movie laughable character choices
where you find yourself going
what a dumb [ __ ] it's like everyone
said to themselves let's take the
original gary
take all the scenes that people love
from it and we'll just use those and
make that the movie and then we'll
modernize it
we'll give them cell phones and youtube
and the ability to upload a youtube
video
incredibly fast this film's just like
showing you a series of events
like a cliff note version of carrie with
no emotional effect in
any of the scenes there's just nothing
consistent in its tones
the horror isn't even
scary this film just felt like a beat
sheet movie like the whole thing just
felt like scene a is gonna go like this
and the rules of screenwriting say that
scene b should be like this
it's like yeah life does suck for this
scary person but for some reason i only
kind of care when you get a documentary
out like bully
and you see how real bullying goes on
today and then you see the bullying in
this which just seems like
hollywood bullying first off chloe grace
moretz as you all know
i love this chick i'm waiting till she's
18.
not gonna say anymore i don't want cops
knocking on my front door but chloe
grace from red she's not
bad in the role she had some moments
that are really good but it was kind of
like watching a more attractive
better acting version of kristen stewart
you know what the huh
those are also the same faces johnny
that makes i'm sorry but
i just don't buy that all these [ __ ]
people
would just hate on her so much have you
seen this woman
look at her even when they try to make
her look ugly she is astoundingly
beautiful i don't care how much she
shrugs her shoulders to
symbolize that she's a shy person i mean
there are times where her shyness really
seems like she's acting
there's just nothing in this film that
really shows us you know like
why these people are picking on her so
much i know there's never really a
reason to be a [ __ ] bully
but there seems nothing wrong with this
person
if we're gonna modern day the carrie
story haven't you guys seen 21 jump
street being weird is the new cool
so carrie really existed i bet you want
to tell people about her telekinetic
powers like since he's basic in the
original carry yeah she's
she's pretty but she's like but chloe
grace moretz is just
beautiful and since he's basic they were
able to make her look like yeah that's a
nerd i could totally buy it you know
she deserves the punishment so no i did
not get lost in the carry character and
that's another huge default on this film
there's like no real
attention for the majority of the movie
on carrie like to really get to know her
it's like every other scene
is just reestablishing that hey she can
move [ __ ] with her mind
not really progressing the plot forward
but she can move [ __ ] with her mind
more [ __ ] she is now moving i'm glad she
can still do her power
like carrie was so underrated and
underdeveloped you know that
it's not chloe grace moretz's fault she
can not be blamed it's the writing
carrie just doesn't feel like the center
piece of the film she doesn't feel like
the heart of the film so sure everything
like revolves around her whenever they
cut back to carry i was always like oh
yeah
carrie is actually in this film the part
where the film actually gets a lot of
things right i'd say is the prom finale
you know all the
[ __ ] they show from the trailer that
seemed like the only time when cast and
crew were on the same level it's like
the director said let's just worry about
the finale
everything else filler julianne moore
talked about her on my don john review
not anymore people saw the trailer and
were like wow julian moore's gonna rock
this
not gonna lie i'd say a solid 40
was effective there are times where the
white [ __ ] is scary there's a
super like made out of steel 60
solid percent that is just laughable
she felt like a goddamn cartoon
character i know the mom's supposed to
be weird in an outcast
but she just doesn't fit in this movie
there were moments
real moments where i would genuinely
crack up
at what she would say or do you know i'm
not one of those like douchebag
wannabe filmmakers who criticizes
everything in every little detail
and then laughs at the movie to be a
[ __ ] smart ass so everyone in the
theater can hear them laugh
i used to be that guy you know there
were times where chloe grace morris and
julianne moore had a good back and forth
man when chloe grace moretz
is 18 and julianne moore
is the hot 89 year old she is
it's never gonna happen i just remember
the mom being a little menacing this mom
is not his mom's more of an idiot
i do like a couple of characters though
the guy who replaced john travolta don't
know his [ __ ] name he's the boyfriend
to the queen bee at the high school he
was pretty believable and the guy who
asked carrie to the prom
kind of has that shia labeouf thing
going on he was charming and sincere
these were the best actors in the movie
they were they were really consistent
there was even some bad editing when you
notice
editing being bad that is
not good a cinematographer looked cool
on the trailer the cinematography in
this
was very lazy it looked like [ __ ]
twilight i mean there's a few cool shots
but for the most part it just didn't
seem to capture like any type of essence
honestly there's so many bad things
about this movie by tomorrow i'm gonna
remember like so many more
and i'm gonna wish i said those too you
guys are gonna miss out on that [ __ ]
on my awesome [ __ ] opinions let me
get straight to the point here
all in all i gotta say carrie got it
super wrong
all right guys thanks for checking out
my review for carrie why don't you go
ahead
scroll that comment box below and tell
me have you ever had sex with a girl
that has telekinetic powers and if you
want to go and follow me on twitter
click that button right there
please click it and if you want to see
more in-depth review of carrie go ahead
and check out my show called reasons to
see
that i do with my buddy jerry where you
know we go
into depth a little more about carrie
i'm repeating myself and last but not
least if you want to get updated every
time one of my reviews is out going to
click on this bottom of my dick to
subscribe
that's right the dick
you know if carrie and i were dating i'd
say carrie
use those telekinetic powers
to make this [ __ ] rise